jerry seinfeld to dave chappelle
comedians have been calling out
cancel culture and political correctness
among
woke audiences but actor seth rogen
thinks they should stop
complaining and just accept it
saying terrible things is bad so if you
said something terrible then
that's something you should confront in
some way shape or form
i don't think that's cancel culture
that's you saying something terrible if
if that's what you've done
well he's spine free greg you have a
backbone and you're hilarious
unlike seth rogan what do you say well i
think probably the dumbest argument
anyone could make
when they're dismissing a concern is
that it's never been a problem for me
so i've heard people use that argument
when there are true claims of sexual
harassment
and when there are false claims of
sexual harassment it works on eddie's
side it's like well you know it's never
been a problem for me
it's basically translate into do not
look
to me for any support when you get in
trouble
you saw how he ditched his best friend
james franco who is a sleazy guy
but seth rogen knew he was a sleazy guy
he worked with him for
years until until franco got too sleazy
and then rogan just dropped him like a
hot potato
not a very good analogy but anyway i
don't know maybe seth doesn't have to
worry
for a few reasons you know he is
completely inoffensive
lately he's never said a shocking thing
in his life except maybe turning down a
joint
he's he's very liberal so that will
offer him some cover
but but there's one thing that he might
have to revisit and that is the rape
scene
in observant report uh which
many would say was played for laughs and
uh
i think maybe he forgot about that i
don't know but that's something that
may end up haunting him although i don't
think he should be canceled for it
because he's playing
a character dana well first of all i
noticed that he said it on good morning
britain
um and of course we know there's uh no
first amendment there right so they have
issues
um but also if if i'd rather be on the
side of
dave chappelle who i think has spoken so
well about this uh kevin hart
jerry seinfeld chris rocks also said
something i would rather i would love to
see all of them
debate this one that would be like an
intelligent square debate i would go to
[Laughter]
juan well i think being rude to people
you know
intentionally demeaning bullying people
i don't think it's funny i don't think
it's
i i agree with him on this point if
that's what you're doing
you know you have to you're gonna have
to pay the price the thing about
american comedy
at its best it does cross lines and
that's why it holds up a mirror to
american society and that's why we love
american comics from you know lenny
bruce to
you know all the way to chris rock
that's that's the best of american
comedy but if you're going to look at
cancel culture dagin
i mean you look at it in terms of the
politics of today where cancel culture
is a big grievance on the right
well liz cheney just got canceled for
speaking the truth
meanwhile marjorie green taylor she's
like making hitler like comments but she
doesn't get
cancelled so you got to start to think
well exactly are we talking about
comedy in the american tradition or are
we talking about
something that's just fits your
political taste at the moment and you're
protecting
we're talking about in comedy jesse
nothing is off limits because humor
and laughter actually make the worst
situations even
tragedies bearable
right so i think greg touched on it a
little bit rogan's talking about himself
his pal franco was accused of a lot of
misconduct by women who were kind of
maybe even 17 and at the time
rogan made a joke about it and now years
later
after the allegations have become a lot
more credible
and a lot more he's now apologized
for making that joke but comedians
aren't
complaining about cancel culture they're
complaining about woke
culture because woke culture kills
comedy and makes everything boring chris
rock said it
they're not getting any edgy material
anymore when the edge is here everyone
just hangs out here now
or the edges come back so far no one's
pushing it juan's right
i mean pryor eddie murphy
george carlin they're not complaining
about their jokes didn't age well
their jokes aged beautifully like dana
perrino
well said wow what do you need what do
you need
anything actually i do have a favorite
i'll talk to you after the show
i can't i thought that was a compliment
or not it was
of course it was i'll just end with this
you mentioned pryor and carlin and eddie
murphy and lenny bruce or
joan rivers or paul mooney who just died
the this bumbling bag of cowardice that
we've been talking about this
segment he will never be mentioned
alongside those greats ever the fastest
seven
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else